all right so the human side of AI so how
do we turn this camera back in on the
human so we're talking about perception
how to detect cats and dogs
pedestrians lanes how to steer a vehicle
based on the external environment the
thing that's really fascinating and
severely under study is the human side
so you know you talk about the Tesla we
have cameras and 17 Tesla's driving
around Cambridge because Tess is one of
the only vehicles allowing you to to
experience in the real way on the road
the interaction between the human and
the Machine and the thing that we don't
have the deep learning needs on the
human side of of semi autonomous
vehicles and fully autonomous vehicles
is video of drivers that's what we're
collecting that's what my work is in is
looking at billions of video frames of
human beings driving 60 miles an hour
plus on the highway in their semi
autonomous Tesla what are the things
that we want to know about the human the
if you're a deep learning therapist and
we try to tear apart break break apart
the different things we can detect from
this raw set of pixels we can look here
from the green to red is a different
detection problem to different computer
vision detection problems green means
it's less challenging it's feasible even
on the poor lighting conditions variable
pose noisy environment poor resolution
red means it's really hard no matter
what you do that's starting on the left
with face detection body pose one of the
best studied and one of the easier
computer vision problems
we have huge datasets for these and then
there is micro saccade the slight
tremors of the eye that happen one at a
rate of a thousand times a second all
right let's look at well first like why
do we even care about the human in the
car so one is trust the stress part is a
so you think about it to build trust the
car needs to have some awareness of the
the biological thing it's carrying
inside the human inside you kind of
assume the car knows about you because
you're like sitting there controlling it
but if you think about it almost every
single car in the road today
has no sensors with which it's
perceiving you it knows some cars have a
pressure sensor on the steering wheel
and a pressure sensor or some kind of
sensor detecting the years sitting in
the seat that's the only thing it knows
about you that's that's it so how is the
car supposed to this same cars is
driving 70 miles an hour on the highway
autonomously how is it supposed to build
trust with you if it doesn't perceive
you that's that's one of the critical
things here so if I'm so if I'm
constantly advocating something is that
we should have a driver facing camera in
every car and that despite the privacy
concerns you have a camera on your phone
and you don't have as much of a privacy
concern there is if it's despite the
privacy concerns the safety benefits are
huge
the trust benefits are huge so let's
start with the easy one body pose
detecting body pose why do we care so
there is a seatbelt design there's these
dummies crash-test dummies with which
which are used to design the safety
system the passive safety systems our
cars and then make certain assumptions
about body shapes
male female child body shapes but they
also make assumptions about the
addition of your body in the seat they
have the optimal position the position
they assume you take the reality is in a
Tesla when the car is driving itself the
variability if you'll remember the cat
the deformable cat you start doing a
little bit more of that you start to
reach bat in the back seat in your purse
your bag for your cell phone these kinds
of things and that's when the crash has
happened and we to know how often that
happens the car needs to know that
you're in that position and that's
critical for that very serious moment
when the actual crash happens how do you
do this is deploying class right so this
deep learning of the rescue whenever you
have these kinds of tasks of detecting
for example body poses you're detecting
points of the shoulders points of the
head 510 points along the arms the
skeleton how do you do that you have a
CNN convolutional neural network that
takes this input image and takes it an
output it's a regresar it gives an XY
position of the whatever you're looking
for the left shoulders right shoulder
and then you have a cascade of
regressors that give you all these
points to give you the shoulders of the
arms and so on and then you have through
time on every single frame you make that
prediction and then you optimize you
know you know these you know you can
make certain assumptions about physics
so you can't your arm can't be in this
place in one frame and then the next
frame be over here it moves smoothly
through space so under those constraints
you can then minimize the error the
temporal error from frame to frame or
you can just dump all the frames as if
there are different channels like RGB is
three channels you could think of those
channels in time you can dump all those
frames together and that's it what are
called 3d convolutional neural networks
you've dumped them all together and then
you estimate the body pose in all the
frames at once
and there are some datasets for sports
and we're building our own I don't know
who that guy is let's let's fly through
this a little bit so what's called gauge
classification gauge is another word for
glance right it's a classification
problem here's one of the TAS for this
class again not here because he's
married had to be home and always
priorities are at this is on camera
should be here there's five cameras it's
what we're recording in the Tesla it's a
Tesla vehicle there's in the but in a
bottom right there's a blue icon that
lights off automatically detected if
it's operating under autopilot that
means the car is currently driving
itself there's five cameras one of the
forward roadway one of the instrument
cluster one of the center stack steering
wheel his face and then it it's a
classification problem you dump the raw
pixels into a convolution in your
network have six classes forward roadway
you're predicting where the drop person
is looking forward roadway less rights
to a center stack instrument cluster
rearview mirror and you give it millions
of frames for every class simple and it
does incredibly well at predicting where
the driver is looking and the process is
the same for majority of the driver
state problems that have to do with the
face the face has so much information
where you're looking in motion
drowsiness so different degrees of
frustration I'll fly through those as
well but the process is the same there's
some pre-processing so this is in the
wild data there's a lot of crazy light
going on there's noises vibration from
the vehicle so first you have to video
stabilization you have to remove all
that vibration all that noise as much as
you can there's a lot of algorithms non
neural network algorithms boring but
they work for removing the state of the
removing the noise removing the effects
of sudden light variations and
vibrations of the vehicle there's the
automated calibration so you have to
estimate the the frame of the camera the
position of the camera and estimate the
identity of the person you're looking at
the more you can specialize the network
to the identity of the person and the
identity of the car the person is riding
in the better the performance for the
different driver state classification so
you personalize the network you have a
background model that works on everyone
and you specialize each individual this
is transfer learning you specialized
each individual network to that one
individual all right there is phase from
civilization fancy name for the fact
they no matter where they're looking you
want the transfer that face of the eyes
the nose of the exact same position in
the image that way if you want to look
at the eyes and you want to study the
subtle movement of the eyes of subtle
blinking the dynamics of the eyelid the
velocity of the eyelid it's always in
the same place you can really focus in
remove all effects of any other motion
of the head and then you just it's the
beauty of deep learning right you don't
there is some pre-processing because
this is you know real world data but you
just dump the raw pixels in you don't
throw all pixels in and predict whatever
you need what you need one is the motion
you can have so it had a way to with a
study where people used a crappy and a
good boys based navigation system so
crappy one got them really frustrated
and they self-reported it as the
frustrating experience or not on scale 1
to 10 that gives us ground truth but it
had a bunch of people use the system and
you know they they put themselves as
frustrated or not and so then we can
predict we can train accomplish in your
network to predict this person frustrate
or not I think we've seen a video of
that turns out smiling is a strong
indication of of frustration
you can also predict drowsiness in this
way gaze estimation in this way
cognitive load I'll brief you look at
that and the process is all the same you
detect the face you find the landmark
points in the face for the face
alignment based on civilization and then
you dump the raw pixel
then for classification step 5 you can
use SVM's there or you can use what
everyone uses now convolution your own
networks this is the one part where CN
NS is still struggle to compete is the
alignment problem is this is why I
talked about the Cascade regressors is
finding the landmarks on the the the
eyebrows a nose the jawline the mouth
there's certain constraints there and so
algorithms that can utilize those
constraints effectively can often
perform better than end-to-end
regressors that just don't have any
concept of what a face is shaped like
and there's huge data sets and we're a
part of of the awesome community that's
building those data sets for face
alignment ok so this is again the TA in
this younger form this is live in the
car real time system predicting where
they're looking
this is taking slow steps towards the
exciting direction that machine learning
is headed which is unsupervised learning
the less you have to have humans look to
the data and annotate that data the more
power these machine learning algorithms
get right so it's currently supervised
learning is what's needed you need human
beings to label a cat and label a dog
but if if you can only have a human
being label 1% one tenth of a percent of
a data set only the hard cases so the
machine can come to the human and be
like I don't know I don't know what I'm
looking at these pictures because of the
partial light occlusions we're not good
at dealing with occlusions whether it's
your own arm or because of light
conditions we're not good with crazy
light drowning out the image this is
what Google self-driving cars they
struggle with when they're trying to use
their vision sensors moving out of frame
so just all kinds of occlusion they're
really hard
for computer vision algorithms and in
those case we want a machine to step in
and say and pass that image on to the
human be like help me out with this and
the other corner cases is so in driving
for example 90 plus percent of the time
all you're doing is staring forward at
the road or in the same way that's where
the Machine shines that's where machine
annotation automated annotation shines
because it's seen that face for hundreds
of millions of frames already in that
exact position so you can do all the
hard work of annotation for you it's in
the transition away from those positions
that it needs a little bit help just to
make sure that this person just start
looking away from the road to the rear
view and you bring those points up so
you're there's a using optical flow
putting the optical flow in the
convolutional neural network you use
that to predict when something when
something has changed and when something
has changed you bring that to the
machine for annotation all of this is to
build a giant billions of frames
annotated data set of ground truth I
want to train your driver state
algorithms in this way you can control
on the x-axis is the fraction of frames
the human hats annotate zero percent on
the Left ten percent on the right and
then the accuracy trade-off the more the
human annotates the higher the accuracy
you approach 100% accuracy but you can
still to do pretty good this is for the
gates classification task when with an
84 per four so almost two orders of
magnitude reduction in human adaptation
this is the future of machine learning
and hopefully one day no human
annotation
and the results is millions of images
like this video frames same thing driver
frustration this is what I was talking
about the frustrated driver is the one
that's on the bottom so a lot of
movement of the eyebrows and a lot of
smiling and that's true subject that's
the subject and the Happy's are
satisfied when I say happy
the satisfied driver is cold and stoic
and that's true for subject that's a
subject because driving is a boring
experience and you want it to stay that
way
yes question a great great great
question they're not absolutely that's a
great question there is a so this is
cars owned by MIT there is somebody in
the back so the comment was my emotions
might then have nothing to do with the
driving experience yes when we continue
that comment is your emotions that often
you're an actor on the stage for others
with your emotion so when you're alone
you might not express emotion you're
really expressing emotion oftentimes for
others like your frustration is like ah
what the heck that's for the passenger
and that's absolutely right so one of
the cool things we're doing well as I
said we now have over a billion video
frames in the Tesla which studied
collecting huge amounts of data in the
Tesla and it's emotional complex thing
right in this case we can we know the
ground truth frustrated they were in
naturalistic data when it's just people
driving around we don't know how they're
really feeling at the moment when I
asked him to like enter in an app how
are you feeling right now
but we do know certain things like we
know that people sing a lot that has to
be a paper at some point it's awesome
people love singing so that doesn't
happen in this kind of data because
there's somebody sitting in the car and
I think the expression of a frustration
is also the same
yes so yeah the question is yeah so or
the comment is that the data set the
solo data set is probably to be very
different from a data set that's non
solo with a passenger and it's very true
the tricky thing about driving and this
is why it's a huge challenge for
self-driving cars for the external
facing sensors and for the internal
facing sensors analyzing human behavior
is like 99.9% of driving is the same
thing it's really boring so finding the
interesting bits is actually pretty
complicated so that has to do with
emotion that has to do with so singing
is easy to find so we can track the
mouth pretty well so whenever you're
talking of singing we can find that but
how do you find subtle expressions of
emotion hard when you're solo and
cognitive load that's that's a that's a
fascinating things I mean similar to
emotion it's now it's a little more
concrete in a sense that there's a lot
of good science and ways to measure
cognitive load cognitive workload how
occupied your mind is mental workload is
another term used and so the window to
the soul the the cognitive workload soul
is the eyes so pupil so first of all the
eyes move in two different ways the way
they move a lot of ways with two major
ways is saccade these are these
ballistic movements they jump around
whenever you look around the room
they're they're actually just jumping
around when you read their eyes are
jumping around and when like you follow
you just follow this bottle with your
eyes that your eyes are actually going
to move smoothly smooth pursuit somebody
actually just told me today that
probably has to do with our hunting
background or as animals I don't know
how that helps like frogs track flies
really well so that you have to like
anyway the point is there are smooth
pursuit movements where the eyes move
smoothly and those are all indications
of certain aspects of cognitive load and
then there is very subtle
movements which are almost imperceptible
for computer vision and these are micro
saccade these are tremors of the eye
here works from here from bill Freeman
magnifying those subtle movements these
are taking that 500 frames a second and
so cognitive load when the pupil that
blacked out in the middle just in case
we don't know the pupil is in the middle
of eye when it gets larger that's in any
cater of high cognitive load but it also
gets larger when the light is dim so
it's like this complex interplay so we
can't rely in the wild outside in the
car or just in general outdoors I'm
using the pupil size even though pupil
size has been used effectively in the
lab to measure cognitive loads
it can't be reliably used in the car and
the same with blinks the point when
there's higher cognitive load your blink
rate decreases and your blink duration
shortens okay I think I'm just repeating
the same thing over and over but you
could imagine how we can predict
cognitive load right we extract video of
the eye here is the the primary eye of
the the person the system is observing
happens to be that the same ta once
again we take the sequence of a hundred
oh it's 90 images that's six seconds 16
frames a second 15 frames a second and
we dump that into a 3d convolutional
neural network again that means it's 90
channels of 90 frames grayscale and then
the prediction is one of three classes
of cognitive load low cognitive load
medium cognitive load and high cognitive
load and those ground truths for that
because we have people over 500
different people do different tasks of
various cognitive load and after some
frontal ization again where you see the
eyes are trance no matter where the
person
looking the image of the faces
transposed in Scituate that the eyes the
corners of the eyes remain always in the
same position after that's when
civilization we find the eye active
appearance models find 39 points of the
eye of the eyelids the iris and four
points on the pupil putting all that
into a 3d CNN model their positions
image I sequence on the left
3d CNN model in the middle cognitive
load prediction on the right this code
by the ways is freely available online
all you have to do sample webcam from
the video stream CNN runs and fastest in
real-time predicts cognitive load same
process as detecting the identity of the
face same processes detecting where the
driver is looking same process detecting
emotion and all of those require very
little hyper parameter tuning on the
convolutional neural networks they only
require huge amounts of data and why do
we care about detecting what the drivers
doing and I think Eric has mentioned
this is on the oh man this is a comeback
of the slide I was criticized for this
being a very cheesy slide in in the past
towards full automation we're likely to
take gradual steps towards that can't
sense enough of that this is better and
especially given that the this is given
today our new president this is pickup
truck country
this is mainly controlled vehicle
country for quite a little while will
like control and control being given to
somebody else to the machine will be a
gradual process is a gradual process of
that machine earning trust and through
that process the machine like the Tesla
like the BMW like the Mercedes the Volvo
that's now playing with these ideas it's
going to need to see what the human is
doing and for that to see what the human
is doing we have billions of miles of
forward-facing data what we need is
billions of miles of driver facing data
as well we're in the process of
collecting that and this is a pitch for
automakers and everybody to buy cars
that have a driver facing camera and let
me sort of close so I said we need a lot
of data but I think this class has been
and and through your own research you'll
find that we're in the very early stages
of of discovering the power of deep
learning for example you know as
recently like Yonghwa Kuhn said that it
seems that the deeper the network the
better the results in a lot of really
important cases even though the data is
not increasing so why does the deeper
network give better results this is a
mysterious thing we to understand
there's these hundreds of millions of
parameters and from them is emerging
some kind of structure some kind of
representation of the knowledge that
we're giving it
one of my favorite examples of this
emergent concept is the Conway's Game of
Life for those of you who knows what
this is
we'll probably criticize me for being as
cheesy as a stairway slide but I think
it's extra such a simple and brilliant
example of how like a neuron in a neural
network is a really simple computational
unit and then incredible power emerges
when you just combine a lot of them in a
network in the same way the this is
called a cellular automata as a weird
pronunciation and and the root is out
it's every single cells operating under
a simple rule you can think of it as a
cell living and dying it's it's it fills
in black when it's alive and white when
it's dead and when it has tor it's if
it's alive and it has two or three
neighbors it survives to the next time
spot otherwise it dies and if it has
exactly three neighbors it's dead
it comes back to life it has exactly
three neighbors that's a simple rule
whatever you get just imagine just
simple all is doing is operating under
this very local process same as a neuron
it's it's it's a or in the way we're
currently training neural networks and
is this local gradient we're optimizing
over a local gradient same local rules
and what happens if you run this system
operating on two really local rules will
you get on the right it's not again you
have to go home hopefully no drugs
involved but you have to open up your
mind and see how amazing that is
because what happens is it's a it's a
local computational unit that knows very
little about the world but somehow
really complex patterns emerge and we
don't understand why
in fact under different rules incredible
patterns emerge and it feels like it's
living creatures like communicating like
when you just watch it
not not these examples this is a this is
the original they get like complex and
interesting but even these examples this
complex geometric patterns that emerge
is incredible we don't understand why
same when your own network so don't
understand why and we need to in order
to see how these networks we be able to
reason okay so what's next I encourage
you to read the deep learning book
available online deep learning books org
as I mentioned a few people you should
Walt first there's a comment amazing
papers every day coming out on archive
I'll put these links up but there's a
lot of good collections of strong paper
lists of papers there is the literally
awesome list the often deep learning
papers on github it's calling itself
awesome but it happens to be awesome and
there is a lot of blogs which is just
amazing that's that's how I recommend
you learn machine learning is I'm blog
and if you're interested in the
application of deep learning in the
automotive space you can come do
research and our group just email me
anyway we have three winners Jeffrey
Hugh Michael Gump and how do you are you
here
hey are you seeing in
oh why here so he achieved
the stunning speed of so this is kind of
incredible so I didn't know what kind of
speed were going to be able to achieve I
thought 73 was unbeatable because we
played with it for a while we couldn't
achieve 73 we design a deterministic
algorithm that was able to achieve 74
believed meaning like it's cheating with
the cheating algorithm that got 74 and
so folks have come up with algorithms
that have done
let's have beaten 73 and then 74 so this
is really incredible and the other two
guys - all three of you get a free term
at the Udacity self-driving car
engineering 900 degree thanks to all
those guys for giving it given that
award and bringing their army of
brilliant so they're people who are
obsessed about self-driving cars and
we've received over 2,000 submissions
for this competition a lot of them from
those guys and they're just brilliant so
it's it's it's really exciting to have
such a big community of deep learning
folks working in this field so this is
for the rest of eternity
we're going to change this up a little
bit but this is actually the three
neural networks the three neural now
three winning neural networks running
side by side and you can see the number
of cars passed there the first place is
on the left second place and third place
and in fact the third place is almost
right now second place is winning
currently but that just tells you that
the random nature of competition
sometimes you win sometimes
Lu's so there's a the actual evaluation
process runs through a lot of a lot of
iterations and takes the medium
evaluation with that let me thank you
guys so much for what wait wait wait
that question yeah so I also you guys
wrote me a note about how their networks
work I did not read that note so okay
I'll post this tells you how crazy this
has been a poster there
the winning networks to online and and I
encourage you to continue competing and
continue submitting networks this will
run for a while and we're working on a
journal paper for this for this game
we're trying to start to find the
optimal solution okay so this is the
first time I've ever taught a class and
the first time obviously teaching this
class and so thank you so much for for
being a part of it
[Applause]
thank you Eric
you didn't get a shirt please come back
please come down and get a shirt just
write your email on the note on the on
the index note thank you